[Applause]
[Music]
it's no secret Israel and the Arabic
countries have never had a good
relationship in fact they've always had
a pretty terrible one three Wars dozens
of diplomatic conflicts and all kinds of
accusations the arab-israeli conflict
was one of the hottest in the second
half of the 20th century so when you
have problems with your neighbors well
you have a problem but if your neighbors
are the largest oil producers in the
world well then you really have a much
bigger problem this is especially true
when you consider that Israel has always
been considered something of an energy
wasteland all attempts to find oil there
were Mun successful
now it is true that having told 1979
Israel has a nice ally in the region can
you guess which country this was well
you might be surprised to learn but it
was Iran yes that's right in the times
of the charr of Persia Iran was a close
ally of Israel after all they both had a
common enemy and that once the Arabic
countries for the first time we see the
new Shia arriving a tournament house to
take over the reins of office in
succession to his abdicated father these
countries had such a close relationship
that in 1978 Israel offered the Shah of
Persia helping building nuclear power
plants yes really however that all
changed in 1979 with Canadians
revolution from that moment on Israel
and Iran went from being good friends
p-well great enemy
the thing is that Israel has always had
two main weaknesses the first is its bad
relations with countries in the region
and the second are the difficulties
they've had ensuring their oil supply
especially when facing conflicts the
Minister for energy in Israel admitted
in 2014
Israel's situation is complicated you
don't have diplomatic relations with
most of the countries from which we
import oil Yosef baretsky however it
seems as if all of this it's about to
change God's gift comes gift that is the
definition Benjamin Netanyahu Israel's
prime minister gave to the latest
discoveries made in the Mediterranean
Sea discoveries which might change
forever the strategic reality of the
conflict region of the Middle East but
now you are probably wondering what
might those discoveries be well pay
attention to this map each yellow piece
represents a newly discovered natural
gas field and these are not small fields
either the last of them to be found and
known as in lab arson is one of the
largest reserves found in the last few
decades Israel has done everything they
could since 1952 in order to find oil or
gas in their territory so that they
could achieve energy independence but
unand over year 2000 all of their
attempts they were unsuccessful if you
were talking ten years ago 15 years ago
and I said Israel would find a big
amount of energy and be almost totally
independent when it comes to energy you
would think that I am crazy
we were the country of milk and honey
but when it came to oil we left it to
our neighbors nati bierenbaum thomas
group however everything started to
change in the year 2000 thanks to
technology when a Texan company Noble
Energy founds the first reserves in the
open sea known as Mari B this first one
it was small that it was a turning point
because they knew that under the sea on
the seabed there were surprises waiting
so noble energy kept exploring the
bottom of the sea and in 2009 they hit
the jackpot
they found that the Tamar reserves shoe
size was significant in fact the reserve
provides Israel with half of their
electricity requirements us a year later
in 2010 well they didn't just hit the
jackpot in the casinos they won the
lottery
after spending only one hundred million
dollars in the exploration of the area
mobile energy is Leviathan an enormous
field so now you're probably starting to
understand what's going on here a little
better it is estimated that this reserve
is larger than all of the ones found in
countries like Bolivia or Mexico and
well this is not the end of the story
because most of this area is still
unexplored
in fact geological studies have
indicated that there is much more
natural gas 5,000 meters below the
surface oh and there is also
oil moreover the government estimates
that the Mediterranean could be holding
a colossal wealth in natural gas and oil
and well this force within Israeli
waters in total the government estimates
that there might be more than three
trillion cubic meters of gas and six
billion barrels of oil all right that's
all well and good but what exactly is 3
trillion cubic meters I mean it's not
exactly easy to picture so you can
appreciate the size of this if these
estimations are right Israel a small
country is only around 80 million
inhabitants could become one of the top
15 countries when it comes to natural
gas reserves and in the top 20 countries
when it comes to oil
[Music]
and this is not just for Israel exports
they've already started at the end of
2016 Israeli companies reached an
agreement with the government of Jordan
to become its main supplier for the next
15 years it's a contract worth more than
ten billion dollars between 50 and 60
percent of that money is going straight
to the coffers of the Israeli government
that's right division politics here in
the next few decades the government of
Israel is going to get an income in the
tens of billions of dollars
Kandice estimations are concerned we
would be talking about hundreds of
billions of dollars and there's more it
looks like Israel lacks continental oil
but there could be massive quantities of
shale oil the type of oil the can only
be extracted through fracking and well
they've already found the first reserves
this means that not only is Israel going
to achieve energy independence but it
could even become a new energy power now
you might know why Netanyahu has
referred to these fields as God's gift a
few years ago Golda Meir the ex prime
minister told this famous joke let me
tell you something that we Israelis have
against Moses he took us 40 years
through the desert in order to bring us
to the one spot in the Middle East that
has no oil gold a mere well it sure
looks like this is no longer the case
and to this discovery the fact that
Israel is one of the most innovative
countries in the world and it's entirely
possible it could soon become one of the
world's wealthiest countries oh it's
also probably important that we mention
another player here then you guess who
were the first to have an interest in
these reserves it was the Russians yep
again really Gazprom actually tried to
buy them this all indicates that Israel
could take a part of the Russian gas
market share in Europe and as you
already know energy means money and
influence
new allies the international situation
of Israel it's always been controversial
Wars political conflicts UN resolutions
the Israeli Minister of Foreign Affairs
has to work harder than Santa Claus on
Christmas Eve consider the last events
from the UN UN Security Council passes
resolution demanding end to Israeli
settlements well despite all of this the
truth is that Israeli foreign policy is
stronger than ever Israeli authorities
are determined to put an end to their
dependence on the United States and
these recent gas and oil discoveries
have certainly helped
for example relations with their
neighboring countries have improved
quickly and by a great amount in 2010
relations with turkey broke down almost
completely when Israel approached the
Freedom Flotilla but now these relations
are being healed this probably has a lot
to do with the fact that arrogance
country uses up massive quantities of
natural gas and their import agreements
with Russia will be over in just five
years and we already know how unstable
relations are lately between these two
countries things are also working out
great with their other neighbors Egypt
and Jordan Israel hasn't just become
Jordan's major gas supplier but the
relations with Egypt's are working so
well that Samar alkie the Minister of
Foreign Affairs watched football's
European Championship final in the
residence of the Israeli prime minister
further the unimaginable could even be
happening some are talking about
reconciliation between Israel and Saudi
Arabia Israel Saudi Arabia are
reportedly negotiating economic ties
Israel is also bonding with tsipras
Greece which has surprisingly become a
close ally in fact the Israeli air
forces now training Greece but the
really major change has been from the
east and in this process India was key
India has made Israel its second-largest
arms supplier behind Russia in the last
decade India has bought from Israel more
than ten billion dollars of military
equipments their relations are so good
in fact in the fing 2015 for the first
time in history the President of India
went to Israel on an official visit
Narendra Modi to become first Indian
Prime Minister to visit Israel
and let's just add one more thing on
this subjects up until now Greeson in VF
had been very critical of Israel as a
consequence of the situation with
Palestine so you can imagine what a step
this was for the Israeli Ministry of
Foreign Affairs and India is not the
only one
Israel is also building a close
relationship with China and they are
negotiating a free trade agreement
besides Chinese businessman they're
making strong investments in the country
and they are even building a port in the
city of Ashdod as part of their Silk
Road project
[Music]
you
closer relationships are developing with
Vietnam South Korea it really seems that
anywhere in Asia Israel is a total
success and only we haven't forgotten
about Donald Trump who for now meds
committed to this
it's our true friend over there and
we're going to protect Israel 100%
anyway there's still a long way to go to
Israel to become an energy power but if
they do it will have a positive effect
for the area stability which but it
would be a very good thing indeed Israel
is well on its way to becoming a great
country but there are still some things
that need to be dealt with like the
conflict in Palestine luckily better
relations with Arabic countries could
help in this matter a lot so now what do
you think these things of this new
energy wealth will contribute to the
solution of this conflict and if you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button and do click that subscribe
button if you want to receive our new
videos they come out twice per week also
do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals for this episode that are not
mine and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you